okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about synthetic geometry
and more than language getting ready for
the initial release of this in the next
version of Wolfram language so the
function currently known as triangle
theta right which I'm going to be very
insistent can't be called triangle data
but we can talk about what it is first
okay so
what is this doing median c1c2 what is
this doing this this is making a line
from I don't even know what enough
facilities okay so the the first
argument specifies a triangle can either
be a list it currently only works in TV
inside there a list of points or you
know triangular polygons they're regular
polygons or something but especially by
the triangle somehow the second argument
is some sort of specification for what
what you want returned so so for
instance in this first one the median
with specification c1 c2 which has to be
a vertex of the triangle is the line
segment from that vertex to the midpoint
of the opposite side of the triangle
okay so in it this is a new construct we
didn't have this construct before all
right come from basically so inside of
synthetic geometry there's a whole bunch
of semi obscure things that had to do
with triangles so we wanted some we
decided rather than have it have you
know five thousand different heads we'd
have one triangle something head let me
just cut back up to speed on what the UM
you know the parts of this that are
uncontroversial okay because this is a
new thing which I don't you know have to
try to understand right let's pull up
the guide page and let's just start off
talking about the things that we think
are you know not so controversial fair
yeah um so you say the guide page is
what is it called synthetic geometry in
D
synthetic that I spell that wrong I know
there we go okay all right so let me
just try doing just because I like doing
this some some some very basic things
okay just to just to get set some
context here okay
so I secants a geometric scene is that
right all right for example ABCD and
then I would say something like um so
let's let's let me just try to
understand what I can type in here so by
the way okay what is polygon angle does
polygon angle work in a and like an
ordinary polygon okay what does planar
angle do okay that's interesting
specifically the 2d thing that you know
always gives you well you can ask for it
but you know the proper angled clockwise
angle the counterclockwise angle etc
okay give me an example a minimal thing
that I can type in here would like a
triangle in a circle or something okay
so it'll be a list yeah and we can do
say circle through circle through list
ABCD okay close comma triangle
of west ABC close list we can do one
more thing here what can we do with the
d4 exactly let's so I'll go back
triangle hey I want to do this I want to
make this I want to do BCD there is my
second triangle okay you find geometric
scene and since the drive nope find
geometric and also just a heads up the
drawing code is a little fragile right
now since we've been having it lets me
stop with this sword very cool
okay so I've got a couple of questions
about this yeah okay so the styling of
the so first of all I I don't like the
fact that this is somehow managed to not
be in the center of the watch image egg
here of the of the bounding rectangle I
don't know why that is looks like a just
simple bug yeah there are many more
problems right okay okay okay no matter
but but okay second issue the styling of
this has this gone through graphic
design at this point no this is from Tim
so it's it's not it's not our own world
but it's also not a fix it's a diesel
okay it's Tim in this meeting no I think
it looks quite nice I mean I'm not I
just would like to make sure that we've
had a proper review of that gutter
design and we report did not thought of
those frozen be able to have plot seems
right but style works okay okay now
what's happening here I am not convinced
about that is the fact that it's
different every time
well that if you want it to be the same
every time you can do it's like getting
the bills it shouldn't give every time
right that's a fee it's supposed to be
different every time I understand that
but it doesn't say random anywhere if
we're going to do that I think we should
have random in the name of this one
well looks like find instance web which
isn't random
not random find instance is completely
deterministic random seeding option but
the random seeding option is by default
set to 1 2 3 4 isn't it probably I don't
remember because that's what I think we
should do here I think we should make
this I really think it's a mistake to
have this not be deterministic I mean
the fact that it has get what I'm saying
I mean so this takes a random seeding
option probably as well right direct so
I claim this should be the default the
problem you could use people I feel they
don't get a good one they don't know
what to do right it's it's impossible to
you know we do the best we can
filtering out the kind of degenerate
scenes but some of them are gonna filter
through and people are gonna want to
want to just try it again and and hope
for hope for a better picture should you
then have a third argument where you can
request a set a number like 2 3 4 that
we do have that I am wondering whether
it should be called random scene
instance because I think it will be
easier for people to understand that but
I feel like we should probably keep the
Belgium ethic if we do it we might want
scene data for something else ok that's
a really long title though and I mean a
geometric and scene are a little bit
redundant at least well ok but with a
question about I strongly believe that
we should have the word random in this
name yeah I'm sorry Michael you say you
do or do not agree I do
you're right kinda it's true weird to do
this every time and you know I mean for
elementary students and so on it's just
too weird
to get a different result every time
vistas name but the future it says I
think is the decider preacher is great
the feature there's no problem with the
feature random you know random functions
don't take a random seating option right
you can block random around them or seed
random around I understand by the way
the obvious thing to do is just is it is
it way should this be random geometric
scene no no that's wrong
what's that have you seen its edge is
not random yes quite well okay
provisionally this name but but I'm not
I agree it's a bit long and ponderous
and if we could shorten it it would be
great um I mean what about random
instance and random instance is a mega
function that later on eats also sings
idea just because like we already have
geometric scene yeah I I think that's a
good idea
Michael and I think that's a good idea
for I can imagine that being useful for
some machine running things in for
example learn distribution yeah I I like
the idea we should propagate this the
let's attend let's let Etienne know
about this idea of having a random
instance function okay now to it ties
point yes it's unfortunate that there's
a random seeding I mean arguably we
could put random seeding into random
word random you know random entity
etcetera etcetera all right anyway let's
continue with this review I think we do
need to talk about the random seeding
thing I would argue that we should put
it into the other random functions um
the conversation I mean it works by you
know I mean are you suggesting you
should take you know that random integer
should take here's what I'm suggesting
but maybe it's absurd but you know
Sandra on our live stream is making in
interesting point which is uh you know
is there a way you could get the seed if
you just found a wonderful instance you
know is there any way to get the seed
and the answer is we don't have any way
to get the seed right now you know I
could imagine some access or getting the
seed but I just don't think yeah I just
don't know we could in principle bake
the seat into some method like option to
dead find options would return it under
related scene yes well that's
interesting or a sub value of the of the
generated scene but it must of course be
some very insight into flu form yeah I
don't think that's a terrible idea
I mean I you know it seems but it's not
totally obvious how you give the seed
and so on okay listen I really like
random instance as a I think that's a
really much better much better name for
this okay let's keep let's keep going
here so if by the way if I say if I just
for fun
add another I'm just to see whether I it
um okay so let's say if I say Circle B
ad well so that's certain circle through
or you can actually do circle so that
will internally it'll recognize that
these it should recognize you through
the same circles
and that's oh I was no fun I wanted to
do something much wilder than that but
you could say in the first argument make
a point
eva's expert seed coordinates actually
what I want to do is I want to have one
of these points be the bisector of a
line how do I get the the midpoint at
the midpoint of the line a B it's a
midpoint of a points no no no I don't
think I forgot whether so midpoint is
it's also down in the agenda all right I
think I've implemented it in here let's
see there's this is why you want the
randomness
sometimes I was very degenerate yeah
what is your degeneracy checking right
now so it's I mean how many instances do
you typically generate it depends on the
scene so currently the theirs isn't
really degeneracy checking per se so
there's a there's a call to find minimum
there are there are certain saddens for
the for the objective function -
hopefully discourage degeneracy but then
the final check at the end is the you
know the constraints are met and the
objective function is at most to 0.01 or
something oh yeah but but in practice
why are we seeing such degenerate cases
showing up it's the first thing that
find minima it in some sense it by the
end of the day I think it's a reflection
of the numerical method for finding it
right it's so we should we should figure
out how to do it a little better
or we should generate three of them and
pick the best of the three or something
right well this is our you know we only
get to make put one foot forward here
right I think probably the way to go is
[Music]
add in some more things about pairs of
points have to be minimum distance apart
and that will make certain scenes
impossible but you know we'll just have
to have the users at their own risk put
in put in concrete no if you do three
cases look do three cases and say pick
the best of three one issue here right
is that you've selected
you know the midpoint of two consecutive
points right so you know am i doing
something stupid yeah I'm doing
something stupid right
so that that's that's always a bad thing
okay that's more impressive um
that's pretty cool actually yeah okay so
I did something dumb it's basically the
point right which caused it to forced it
to be degenerate right either degenerate
or you know really really big
differences in the size of the two
circles which is why you ended up with
something that looks like that yes well
okay fair enough fair enough
okay I've got another comment here which
is about the the design here yes we know
this one yes justice these have to
change in size yeah okay no problem
okay all right let's get let's get down
to but I really like this is a real
improvement it really helps okay let's
keep going here so so we got all of
these cool functions cool okay fine all
right
I get it okay now what do you want to do
what is triangle data so triangle data
is basically mushing a bunch of triangle
functions all under one head and so and
the outputs can be different some of
them are geometric objects some of them
are scalars alright so I doubt that
that's the best of ideas okay so to put
all of those together I mean look
triangles are a big thing in the world
having 5 triangle functions is not the
end of the world so to speak having a
hundred triangle functions is ridiculous
okay
right but so what I'm possibly
suggesting is taking these buckets here
and making each of these a function
possibly so for example this one here
you know just as a possibility triangle
Center and then the default Center is
the centroid right and then but then
there's a lot of other exotic centers
also some of those are
really centers what are they look foot
okay it's the foot of an altitude ok
well then again maybe we break those
apart I mean maybe maybe there's a what
I'm suggesting is that what we aim for
is a collection of like like these for
example the centroid the circumcenter
the orthocenter blah blah blah
those are all conceptually the center of
the triangle
they have different specific ways of
being the center but conceptually
they're all in the bucket of center of a
triangle the only knock I would have
against this so currently triangle data
you know given a triangle you're only
allowed to return one thing from it but
if we wanted to allow returning say the
in center and the inside we want to do
that why don't just have two functions
though I mean I don't see the point of
it why would we want to return those two
things together I mean in terms of
graphics if you wanted if you wanted to
display the circle and its center and
you know several things about the same
triangle at once currently we can't do
that but theoretically we could have
well absolutely but then we when we have
a list of things here triangle Center
blah the list ability is not a huge
problem here the cross list ability of
let's not worry about that let's keep
going in this in this direction for a
second so I'm gonna let's break apart
these things just so that we have a um I
just want her I'm just breaking these
apart just so we can type in in between
them um okay so um now okay so first of
all these circles now you've already got
icy circumstellar
okay the circumcircle takes a triangle
right it's the same as circumspect
but it returns a circle instead of a
sphere well why are you calling it
circum
I mean so okay first of all so the first
argument here
I claim of all these functions should be
either the naked points or the triangle
object do you agree yes the case okay
all right okay so I'm gonna suggest I
mean again let's let's take a look at
this idea okay so triangle circle it
would default to the circumcircle and
okay so let's keep going here so this
one I claim should be called um
placements triangle measure I would say
triangle measure potentially and then I
don't know what it default it probably
defaults to the area because that would
be the obvious triangle measure I think
yeah I think we should avoid measure it
cement or something like that yeah okay
I don't particularly like measurement is
there something better
I agree measure may not be right because
like the height triangle value triangle
property what sir it's not really a
characteristic because property would be
things like isn't it okay where do we
get to ask is it an acute inner or an
obtuse you know is it a scalene is it a
gosh so long saving said that word is it
a scalene triangle' do we have any
function that answers is it a scalene
triangle not yet those we come together
is asking for like we wanted in the
second round the dedicated function for
asking for numerical values about
objects so inside of geometric scene we
have something called geometric
assertion which is kind of the way of
asserting that certain properties of
geometric objects but we don't currently
have a geometric assertion of triangle
comma
staying right that's an assertion so
that there's also the point of being
able to say okay so you've got a
geometric assertion of object comma
property right right okay so what we
also want to get is we could imagine a
geometric value possibly of object comma
property which tries to compute it like
is it a scalar triangle scalene triangle
I'm not sure I'm not sure that's right
but um but the property would be as
things would be scallion cure how do it
what would be the name okay so here is
there will be a triangle here this would
be scalene yeah I will basically be
scalene q okay um it might just be
scaling but but down here okay there's
nothing to have to be a q1 no it does
not have to be a q1 it's what well I'm
proposing like it that could say area
for example so geometric value would be
like a super function of triangle data
that's what genetic where you would be a
super func that would apply to all of
Charles's geometry not just synthetic
one yeah so it may be to super but I
mean triangle value then you're
suggesting here what other possibilities
do we have possible names for triangle
yeah at the bottom there's the possible
triangle property triangle contract
triangle construction triangle feature
triangle detail you know pseudo suit but
those are trying to think of this the
whole thing yeah which i think is a
mistake okay let's look at these other
ones here um so this would be probably
triangle cvn what is acedia I've never
heard of that what is it
this levian is a line segment from the
vertex of a triangle that intersects the
extension of the boundary or the
extension of the opposite side of the
okay so I have a question for you
well what do you predict is the total
number of hits to that word on the way
I'm gonna predict 200,000 okay here goes
that's high
where'd he fell I was gonna say 200,000
then I then I round it down it's 268,000
the the top one being Syrian capital
okay never heard this word before
literally never heard it who here had
heard this word before am I just poorly
educated I had more in meetings about
this functionality no doesn't count
where did it come from save right so
save as a mathematician and so there's a
save as theorem and he also worked with
these sorts of things so it's okay well
I've never heard of it is Roger in this
meeting had Roger ever heard of it right
there's no Charles ever heard of it yes
you have a bad day to point that where
did you learn about it did you learn
about it like in high school or do you
learn about it in doing yeah in high
school you weren't doing much better
highs to fill the night it apparently I
did not hear about this well he went to
some sort of francophone high school so
that's true through that battle wins is
a factor as well
Flip Phillips on our live streamers say
he said if it put triangles or his life
okay look I just don't think this word
is well-known so what what is the what
is the main thing this is a line this is
some line related to a triangle but I
don't really understand what some of
these other ones are I don't even
understand what the seven thing is so
let me just understand that from my
education since I obviously missed the
summer you're good
opposite side in boundary or not sevens
I forgot I added those in there there's
a line segment which joins the vertex of
a triangle with a point on the opposite
side right okay so usually relevant to
this usually you're given the triangle
of vertex on the triangle the points not
on the triangle which is the seven point
which you know can be anything and then
the then you draw the line segment from
the vertex through the seven point until
it terminates at the the opposite side
of the triangle okay I get it
so is it essentially um is it is an
essentially triangle line through I mean
is it the analog of circle through okay
okay let's try and name the ones that we
can name here and then let's go back to
the other ones okay
what is this what is the triangle I
actually have a picture of the medial
triangle is the triangle whose vertices
are the midpoints at the sides of the
triangle anti medial triangle is the
triangle whose medial triangles the
original triangle and then triangle is
the triangle itself triangle we don't
exactly have to name right it was just
to have a default you know the
specification was not yet
the return and there are many more named
triangle instructions right and we could
support um okay okay so a named triangle
construct I mean how many named
Pentagon's are there other named
Pentagon's - I'm sure they're named
quadrilaterals what well I'm joking
about Pentagon's but quadrilaterals
there surely are lots of named ones
there aren't Wendy named once okay and
of triangles how many well I mean are
there are named there named
quadrilaterals but are there named
quadrilateral constructions
not many know not many of these okay so
for triangles this kind of you know I
mean I'm making up names here which are
not good but but you know modified
triangle that's transformed triangle
there's a right triangle yeah better
that's better
it's definitely better yeah I mean yeah
go ahead
no I was saying I I would like all these
things to start with triangle I would -
yes I would I would think triangle
contract I guess is - it's also hard to
read because contract could be a verb
alright try all construction it doesn't
necessarily have to be a triangle yeah
that seems a bit weird um okay but let's
let's keep going with more of these two
names and just understand which ones we
have a definite okay so triangles Center
I think that there's a bucket of those
that seem very reasonable what is this a
median point maybe actually is a center
so there are those yeah all of those are
validly filled thought of as centers of
various kinds yes except for the last
three rate oh yeah CV an endpoint is not
but it is not midpoint it's not maybe an
endpoint if not an angle bisecting CD
name was a second line there okay so
those are essentially triangle points of
some kind triangle special points yes
last ones are endpoints of Ian's well
that's that's lovely but but is triangle
point a reasonable name I wonder if it
should be triangle and point but it's
not necessarily an end not right well
they are well no they the foot is the
endpoint of the altitude the midpoint is
the endpoint of the median the Cimmerian
endpoint of the endpoint of the
Cimmerian and the angle bisecting
sending in pointers yeah this is
very 19th century character to some of
these names I don't think we can
guarantee that any named points we come
up with in the future can they
necessarily be either centers or
influenced by the way when would miss
mr. Semyon sever or ever
is that like from the 1600s or something
or is that like come what is that like
I'm just I'm sorry I'm just doing my
little education that are no sever okay
I was right 1647 to 1734 okay so it's
the same time as the as all those weird
things
not the goethe manian that was later
that the things I'm oh gosh what are
those things called web where you
transform quintics Michael you know what
I'm talking about the all those weird
theorems for transforming quintics to
not teach teach yeah yeah yeah right
it has another strange name yeah house
churn house that's right churn house
transformations um well I mean so okay
so the Savion thing it just seems really
weird
I mean if it's like okay are these all
versions of altitudes we do not the
easiest trust classified by by return
type so line infinite line point circles
are young and then it's also very
extensive the for the future just purely
structural okay like drive right okay or
something like drive triangle line
although drive triangle triangle okay so
you could to be a pretty good
yeah drive triangle polygons to try all
gonna be triangles but I think that's a
hack I think it's the naming okay okay
so so the point here okay let me just
understand
okay those are infinite lines so those
are going to return an infinite line
object right so usually an angle
bisector in terms of the triangle you'd
most people want to see in which is that
line segment which is why we have angle
bisectors even but we're also
introducing just a general head angle
bisector which returns in the infinite
line so that was kind of a question of
should angle bisector in terms of
triangle data or whatever we call it
should probably return the same type of
thing but we'd see the thing which is
super confusing I mean some of these
things are really like perpendicular
bisector you have that as an actual head
here yes this is the perpendicular
bisector of what you've got ABC so which
one is that the perpendicular bisector
all I have to say list perpendicular
bisector comma these by default it
assumes the the second vertex so just to
be clear we have a separate head
perpendicular bisector that just works
on you know a line segment or or two
points yes I understand
yeah and generally the things that have
their own name are a little bit more
extensible and not trustful tireless
fair enough
you know Sandra on a live stream is
suggesting the rather obvious solution
of suggesting that but once we have this
on Vidan not back at a two argument
version of triangle data where first
argument is type ii common name well
yeah but it yes but it's a it's a well
this isn't type this is some totally
weird thing here no no and then kind of
because the because the name implies the
type via lied the type I still think it
look I'm not big on this derived thing
if there's a different name yeah I don't
think I mean except possibly for the you
know for deconstructions I don't think
that derived is right well I look
triangle circle is a nice name for what
it is but sorry like which one do you
think is not derived in reason of the
sense of the world area perimeter in
angle measure maybe like certainly
something like you know altitude is a
construction but area and exterior angle
or they're not the right there just
properties how about um
a triangle derived circle
Middle East means you know triangle
derived circle triangle derived line if
you see that in a piece of code it's not
completely obscure what it might be I
think without the hyphen between
triangle on the right not sure yeah I
think I prefer the derived triangle why
I think it's I don't like putting
derived first yeah III perfectly okay
with triangle derived and I like the
fact that triangle comes first it
certainly I mean we granted we don't
have the literal - but they don't think
that's that's unique to this name you
know I mean but let's see whether what
the other ones work here
I mean triangle derived infinite line
that's fine um ok triangle derived
triangle is very weird
I think we triangles right polygon they
just have all triangles but we might
until we say it hex are good from a
triangle yeah okay fine it's a hack it's
a naming hack guys but I think it's an
acceptable naming hack right okay so
what else do we have here we have
triangle what about this thing well
triangle derive point is fine although I
have to say I would love to have
triangle Center if that's what they all
are a while ago we didn't have triangle
Center but then we they got merged and
all this other stuff well I would argue
that triangle Center I don't know how
useful triangle Center is how commonly
does it occur I mean I could imagine
triangle Center of all these things I
think triangle Center had probably the
most common I think so too because I
mean centroid circumcenter I mean
orthocenter is very big fine
well then I mean I think we could
potentially have triangle Sun to be a
separate thing which is you know a
special case of triangle derive point
okay so the one remaining thing then
we've got triangles or
value that's a little weird that's a
little weird because what are those
things those are scalars basically right
and again I'm going to assert they're
not really derived okay well maybe it's
the wrong name to those ones yeah that's
more like a triangle calculation yeah
which is you know triangle measurement
triangle are the all measurements well
well they're scalars so they have to be
measurements of some kind if they are
scalar must be measurement yeah I don't
think triangle measurement is terrible
for those ones triangle measurement you
know the triangle comma height that
seems in consistent with our other use
of measurements for example um image
measurements and things like this yep
all right well I'm liking these let me
very for completeness we would have
infinite hot line all the triangle
derived infinite Hoffler
I know but trust for completeness I mean
it really begs for it if you said I
personally think we've gone too far
spinning I mean I was wondering if you
really need line and infinite line maybe
not why we just return if we return an
infinite line if it is an infinite line
Wow triangle construction and
construction so what are you proposing
the triangle construction would be lines
and lines that doesn't seem stupid to me
let's let's look through that for a
second okay so that would be something
like triangle construction I don't think
that's a construction I mean a
construction is like you know a thing
with a ruler and compass that has six
steps type thing it's not just solve to
construct all right what's this
right which would be triangle construct
which is hopeless because it's got a
round problem etc etc but I don't
disagree that having a having a single
thing that represents something that
comes out okay what could we do there
triangle feature was one suggestion I'm
not sure if it's quite right for this
not really right I mean the circumcircle
is hardly a feature structure no that's
not right I think it's hard to read
I think constructed primitive it's a CAF
exploitive is it graphics no you know
it's a CAF extreme ative it's aligned
the point triangle it's either us color
or it is a CAF expensive look of these
triangle construct which unfortunately
gets read as a as a verb too much I mean
let's look at what it would look like it
would say triangle construct and then it
would be some triangle and then it would
say something like altitude I mean that
that also works as a verb right
construct the altitude of this triangle
yeah I agree
not
terrible and then okay so then the other
functions that we would have our
triangle measurement other ones that
returns Carlos right yes those are the
ones returning scalars and then just for
jollies we would probably have triangle
Center which would be fine from in terms
of construct because we're not we would
not return a point head we don't later
kill the cord that's why would we return
the code for the center yes
so that would separate it from the
contract because it's not a geometric
it's not a I see I see I see
so where would things like flip fall in
here I would be fine with put in
midpoint showing up under triangle
construct so remember that they are
points than their point as in P oh I and
T's I wouldn't they would never be
allowed to be just coordinates then that
makes things hard for us because we want
to say things like a equals the foot of
some fine but then okay so look triangle
Center triangle point doesn't seem to me
to be a hopeless thing to have in here
as well which would give you your foot
you know given the triangle there's the
foot of the triangle as XYZ but the
confusion is that we have the double
meaning of point explain that to me yeah
the uppercase point could refer to point
open/close as well as to the pair of
coordinates which we also call a point
oh yeah I forgot this isn't 2d this to
you I feel like okay well what is when
you say a in in geometric scene when we
you say a does it mean apo int point or
does it mean an XY it means an ex-wife
although it does I mean Jim inside
geometric scene I do handle point
but there's more for convenience not as
a matter of well okay so the real
question which you which we were sort of
sweeping under the rug here is what does
triangle construct return does it matter
to you because if it's gonna return a
circle it has no choice but to return
the site right so I think it has to
return the capital point right yeah I
mean because we are not speaking about
subsets like relation in principle the
code could be smart enough to identify
uppercase points with its first argument
what if we what if we combine triangle
Center and triangle point into a
triangle location I don't I don't I'm
not keen on I think if we're gonna do
that we should call it know if it
returns a capital P point then we'd have
to do things like say point of a equals
triangle construct bah-bah-bah or we
would have to identify capital P points
with coordinates well why aren't we
doing that I think we're gonna end up
having to do that I think it would be
fine for the synthetic geometry but I
feel like it will lead to a lot of
trouble it's on this world Charles can
you comment on this I doubt it is
something you have to resolve anyway so
my question is look to me if this
function has to return a circle symbolic
primitive then there's no way it can
return anything other than a point
symbolic relative if you're it's only
for synthetic geometry that we have this
idea that variables can be points not
really I think the problem is much
earlier it's you me as a set of points
and you make a line between the points
you can't make line of uppercase point
comma uppercase point you must take
things out we should maybe we should fix
that Michael it's
we are going to fix anyway I mean we
have that general problem in geometry
you say you know X Y element of e lists
of a line or you see point X Y element
of a line is a general problem you have
you know the whole geometry thing we you
know we are thinking about well I mean
there's a very simple resolution of the
basic thing we just discussed which is
something which I'm surprised doesn't
already work which is just make this
work but by Rilke you mean formatting
everything so you mean by a I mean it
could just evaluate to the line of the
of the point coordinate I think people
did not like this idea why because the
geometry sinks are sometimes in large
graphics cause with millions of seeing
like studying heading evaluation who is
we we avoid evaluation fine but right
fine and then simply render it the same
and for synthetic geometry treated is
the same that will be my thought I mean
I can't see what this could mean other
than the flattened version let's let's
look at some other things and let's come
back to the site what would mean
something is it mean basically like if
you would have a curve fix of line X Y
by Y and then you have a graphics of the
same line plus the points you would see
slightly different end points so it
could mean something else would be not
unnatural
what this is like open sets closed sets
no abstract points like a trusty line
would be overall same sickness but this
one could have a little bit sicker end
point right because lines are really
multi lines but so that it's not too
obvious that they all be the identical
bit okay
geometrically Durante can't wait I mean
you're Justin Tuck jump out you're
hungry yes yes but Michael's point is I
mean that it's like you know mesh arrow
you know like in enlist line plus mesh
arrow true yes I think there's a
question for Brett who I'm sure is not
here to a point on this so let's let's
take that question to Brett and let's
consider it I think there will be some
solution to what this means and
certainly for purposes of symbolic
geometry I think we can assume this
means the same thing as the line with
the coordinates so with that statement
you know triangle construct which I'm
reading purposefully correctly so to
speak
triangle measurement how important yeah
I mean to me these sub pieces of
triangles these points and things seem
like they would be more naturally a
separate function I mean and definitely
the foot is different from see the
problem of the foot the foot isn't
enough right I mean yeah if I'm giving
triangle with points ABC the foot is
below B right right yes this would be
assumed for the football be okay the
you wanted the foot below a you do list
put comma a oh why aren't I doing you
know commute the triangle CA B so when
are seeing descriptions we would have to
write because if you want to do if you
wanted to say specify the triangle once
like try equals triangle ABC and then
you want things from different also had
a syntax all I don't know if that's
currently yeah all work all works too
they weren't although meeting this but
all I really hate putting foot and B in
a list I don't see how it could mean
anything
I mean if you you know it's more
something like that well we didn't like
using one reason we didn't like using
rules it's certain cases you need more
than one extra specification and since
rule is okay thanks - let's enumerate
what where is an example of one where
you need more than one specification c
BN n cv n because perceiving you need
the vertex and then you need the Sirian
points I mean it's almost like we'd be
talking about you know here putting in
something like vertex C V n point you
know that we have to kind of spell it
out like this I just don't know if these
things have a sort of random grab-bag of
different parameters that they need it's
going to get pretty confusing i we
considered the rural music rule to start
with but we go what about using an
association with the parameters
specified in these I mean right we have
this all over the place right where you
have a string and if the string takes
parameters it's less string comma
parameters I know we do have it it's not
my favorite feature um let's look ahead
we're gonna come back to these in a
minute let's look ahead
the other things you want to talk about
because I think we're I think we're
reasonably close to resolving this um I
tend to think triangle contract triangle
measurement and a little bit of extra is
probably the right way to go okay all
right let's keep going here um okay
nested lists versus right so this is
this was part of what we were talking
about you have to evaluate that there
the the grid thing the second thing
should expand that
okay one two so the this is back to kind
of the original syntax for triangle data
there's a question of for instance for
like a CV and for an angle bisector if
you wanted the infinite line versus the
the line segment should there be just
two different string heads like angle
bisector and angle bisector angle
bisecting CVM like we had or should we
have a list of separate strings like CV
and line comma or like okay so it's it's
like we could have a thing which gives a
collection of things like it is a
bisector and it is a non infinite thing
and so on right I'd always parameters
there oh good so I don't like having
angle by second C be an end angle
bisector I would rather have just angle
bisector and then maybe do list say what
you could agree with that but the
problem is by the time we've got all
these random parameters here this is
starting to look really really
complicated
can we go on and just look at okay I get
this question um there's a question
so midpoint is a new contract so the
question is should it return pointer
coordinates I think if it I think it
should do what what all these other
things do if you feed it points it
returns a point if you feed it
coordinates it returns coordinates
whatever the first one is whatever a is
probably whatever yeah if you really
want to deal with the case of the two
being different and the other question
is you know it works on two points
absolutely should work on a line okay
the big question is what is doing
polyline I don't think it should work on
a polyline I don't think that's well
maybe a polyline but could go different
with off the awk distance in principle
it could work on any rectifiable curve
that that'll be hard
version one feature but but midpoint I
mean what it would do is go a certain
distance along the arc length right
right along our way right but we're
gonna want generalized midpoints they're
gonna want one third of the way if we
give them this they're gonna want one
third of the way okay which is an
argument to have the first argument be
in a list which I favor anyway okay
I would favor doing this I would say
midpoint of the list pt1 pt2 because
that gives you the opportunity to just
go ahead and say midpoint of a line
which is one argument thing all right it
also gives you the opportunity to have a
second argument somewhat obscurely which
is how mid do you want your midpoint so
to speak like a like a quantile you know
it's like the difference between a you
know a flowery median and a quantile but
but um
Charles are you okay with you know that
would kind of order but you know give an
order to the line well I don't I don't
mind any feature as long as we you know
if it's a geometric feature we are ready
to support it for all the Coit
committees right hey I'm gonna question
this is a very naive question but but
there are quantiles right for for median
type stuff what is the analog why isn't
there a am I being really stupid for a
mean why isn't there instead of saying I
want halfway through the data I want
three quarters of the way through the
data my being stupid is that something
totally obvious know what that means
well I'm saying that that you say median
is if you have or you know a list of an
ordered list of numbers the median of
the middle line no it's the halfway
through the thing and that's why the
quantiles can be the you know Q of the
way through the thing right but but in
this case when I'm saying you know I'm
saying oh you can have a midpoint line
but you can have the three quarters of
the way midpoint line what does 3/4
right so I guess I see it's like a
distribution it's like a uniform
distribution of points within that 3/4
is with respect to a uniform
distribution you can say if you've got a
line from A to B it's it's the you know
the point 3/4 of the way along is
well-defined well only if you assume
that there's you know a beginning and an
ending
your it assumes an ordering like what if
you just had an implicit region in the
first story then what's your point
I mean then then what does three
quarters mean but youkai midpoint still
means something
well doesn't matter which end you start
from okay there are some well-known
geometry theorems involving find a point
one-third from A to B
okay so it's a future question what
whether the midpoint has to be
generalized for second argument Sandler
is pointing out that that has to work
which of course is true
are you for sure what what is that
that's a that's a semicircle oh sorry I
didn't read it carefully enough
what is it is it what the circuit was it
yeah it's a mid point on the circle just
like if it's gonna be on a curve it's
the midpoint on the curve it is enough
the odd distance but what about if the
circle is depower the implicit object
pain on an object we doesn't have the
head circle or an MPC twitch on a
parametric region can be a circle so
what we did in midpoint of those torus a
there again you're saying a parametric
region that happens to correspond to a
circle exactly so here we are kind of
making the relation because the head is
a circle of expression so it's midpoint
of a psycho well of a semi circle yeah I
mean I don't know whether we return if
that if you didn't have the third
argument circle there yeah what is the
midpoint of a full circle nothing who
knows all right so look there's there's
some question about how far the midpoint
goes but the concept of having a
midpoint and that it's two others its
initial arguments should be in a list
seems okay to me any objections and and
you know if you feed it points it
returns points if you difference of all
points that returns two more points you
feed it coordinates the returns
coordinates I don't think you can return
some unless pay symbolic points you mean
explicit lists right I don't see how
midpoint of a comma B can evaluate I
think Stephen meant fights in public no
what I meant was but perhaps I'm wrong
if you feed it something like this what
is it doing if you feed it this is it
returning you know mean of x1 y1 x2 why
- an appoint I think that's fine yeah
okay but point I mean we can remove the
list and evaluate it and see what it
actually does well so the currently it
only accepts coordinates those not
accept okay all right let's keep going
perpendicular bisector so then this is a
just the question of so angle bisector
should obviously be able to take points
as well right
and what does angle bisector return does
it return a line infinite line okay
but it does that it actually computes it
yes okay okay
so one idea for some of these the the
Sevilla nation of these lines that is
cookie cutter in them to inside the
triangle which is what you're basically
talking about there of the you know the
finite line segment that seems to be a
general operation that comes up in a
bunch of places that is taking an
infinite line and chopping it to within
the triangle okay but is that something
that I mean so is that sufficient to say
that's your definition of well fair
enough okay should put the goodbye so
take a list of points or a sequence of
two points it sounds like a midpoints
taking what's the points and angle
bisector takes a list of points then
perpendicular bisectors yeah right
should take a list of points but what
does it actually return here and so I
see so it's in front line because the
perpendicular bisector also works on a
line and so we clearly wanted to take a
list of points
yeah we clearly do because it yes yeah I
mean and but then let me just understand
if I say graphics of line of comma
infinite line
that infinite line got to coordinates
there that aren't so it's so infinite
line has two arguments structures one is
a list of two points the other is a
starting point in a vector so this one
for perpendicular bisector has a
starting point as the midpoint and they
make a minute vector okay okay
but now okay so if I wanted to so what
you're telling me is that if I say
region intersection of that infinite
line with a triangle let's see is it
like this no it's just one more one what
the heck does that mean a two
dimensional empty region why is that an
empty region well triangle bigger my
gosh that's actual math wow that's cool
does anybody know we can do this yes
there's more lot more becomes really
actually where each intersection fails
because you're doing some you know
bizarre mesh region with some boolean
region and you know somewhere it falls
down Wow by the way these are nice
examples if you need examples for
documentation and things I mean it's not
was not obvious to me that stuff like
this would work
it's pretty cool okay in any case um
okay so we've agreed on on perpendicular
bisector okay
sub values for geometric scene
um so this is so if you're use you know
I guess it's random instance of
geometric scene you get a scene and then
you want to extract things from the
scene print for for instance it normally
return something with the geometric
scene head that formats as graphics but
if you want just a graphics object you
could use you know spring graphics if
you request multiple instances of the
scene how do I do that I do that with
random instance comma two or something
yeah okay that's fine just like I can
say random word or something comma three
or something like that um so open up
those yeah so so if you do that it the
head of this is still geometric scenes
and each if you copy and paste any of
these individual scenes they're at each
of their head this film geometric scene
but by default it formats is a tab view
it's not a good idea
as opposed to it being a list well right
because if it's a list people are gonna
think that the head is are more likely
to think that the head is a list and not
geometric scene so the idea is if you
want a list of these individual things
where the head is actually list you
would have this sub value and in and I
were arguing I would prefer sub value
string list II would prefer some value
string instances well but graphics
graphics gives you the graphics by the
way you did said they were getting of
this meeting that this extra space here
is gonna get fixed up right we have to
do this yes yeah we'll deal with it okay
so yeah graphics if it has a graphics
returns either I just Swingle traffic or
most of graph or a list of graphics
what is instances return
so instance so he and I were arguing
over what it should return because I
think list should be he thinks instances
you would return what list returns down
here what's the difference in what list
returns list is returning individual
geometric yes these they're these have
had geometric seen graphics has had
graphics well I think that the obvious
thing to do would be to say scenes in
this case because this is the case of
plural scenes right right but the but
that tabview will return a tab view
it'll have hem tab view but it's an
individual thing inside the tab you will
have had geometric scene wait what
you're suggesting yet another sub value
well I look at page yeah but it's just
it's a pay you that return something
convenient for you oh the fault return
value it's just a leave right right the
default return value is if it's just a
single scene its head you metrics the
default if you have one scene do if you
do find instance right you want seen
what you saw active all of them to her
disturb you know the hey it formats as a
tab you the head is still geometric
saying yeah well I don't understand why
you need the sub value tab view and if
you don't like scene of scenes why not
seen of scene list and then it's right I
say yeah I grade we don't need tab view
and if we get rid of tab view then you
can do yes seamless that's fine I don't
see why we need to a because we get this
new tab so then fun so then what we
would have a scene of graphics unseen of
scene list and scene of seamless doesn't
make any sense if you just have a single
scene list yeah right yeah because what
we had is sub value tab you would just
be tab
you've seen it seamless that's stupid
sorry what are you saying it would
really help if you open the rough page
for geometrically yeah I think nobody's
talking about the same thing getting
right right they're worse is getting
properties we don't even talk about
conclusions and things
what is quantities so for when you're
describing geometric scene if you want
to say have a scalar quantity rather
than a they may been a point that is
abstract then the first argument to
geometric scene can be a list of two
lists the first list will be the list of
abstract points the second list will be
the list of abstract quantities well I'm
so wasn't as possible functions to be
used within method include that's really
weird that's really weird I've never
seen us do that before I have not seen
this before seems awfully weird so just
so I understand the if I go back up to
my original example here and I take this
creature and I say conclusions here so
that'll be since we didn't run the fine
geometric conjectures there are no
conclusion so just if it was at this
point right so if you so inside the
geometric scene yes I actually find
geometric conjectures yeah
do we have did we load the conjecture
cards I forget whether this is going to
work it's loaded but not guaranteed it
will work yeah also I don't know what if
there any conjectures and final mmm I'll
try it no no see they worked and it
found no conjecture
yes what would conjectures look like are
so similar things right it'll be
something like you know a B C equals CDE
great okay hey listen look logistics
here we're running out of time um and I
think we made some good progress on
these let's work through this some
triangle construct triangle measurement
thing that seems reasonable I'm a little
bit unhappy about this weird sort of pot
of different function you know
parameters and so on that have to be
given here um and I've already forgotten
what no I haven't what the Sirian thing
is um the I think yeah we're gonna need
another review of this because we
haven't really dug into documentation I
think it's gonna need at least another
hour and a half and you know very soon I
mean this functionality is wonderful let
me ask you another question what is our
plan for the Wolfram Alpha integration
of this a we need I thought running on
it and then we need a inductive importa
from what
so from drawings yes no yes and no not
kind of drawings in the sense of given
PDF but in the sense of interactive no I
understand that I understand that so and
has there been any interaction with the
cloud team about that yes and is it
promising is it hopeless is it because
of other projects taking higher poverty
right now a little bit on hold okay but
what do we imagine we imagine that with
geometric drawing there one will be able
to give constraints in the geometric
drawing layer which would do some simple
stuff right they're just you know being
able to visualize things and then as
soon as you press go it will feed it
into the engine and actually generate
conjectures very much so we have
basically you draw something and then
the toy gets converted in basically the
second argument of geometric
scene and then be honored and similar
instances with John Clooney actress
that's pretty neat
okay and how strong is what we're able
to do here how I mean if I if I gave
something more industrial less
educational would it still work with
like a hundred triangles and things a
hundred or be there there there are
limits as it does have to be kind of
reasonable but it does do a couple
non-trivial see leaps right there are
some of the more impressive things it
does is actually like there are certain
constructions where you know for a human
it's you know describing the scene
there's a very particular way you have
to do the construction to find you know
maybe there's only one in it so sorry
asking about construction until like a
ruler and compass construction like you
know I don't know Gauss's construction
of the whatever it was this yes the
seventeen going can we do that no well I
mean we could say regular seventeen if
you say here if you couldn't write down
two steps right yeah we could we can
write down the step we could end up with
the regular seventeen yes yeah yes
explain that so what would it mean to
write down the steps
well the the steps is Gauss's a
description of how you use a ruler and
compass together regular seven no I I
don't quite understand what a
construction is in terms of all these
are more or less assertions I mean this
is like Euclidean assertion so sorry
when I say the construction I met the
the actual can't construct let me
rephrase to the inning it rephrase this
there are describing a scene there are
some instances where you know up two
translations rotations whatever there's
there's only one scene that satisfies
satisfies a given set of constraints and
is apparently you know difficult for
human mathematicians to to come up with
that I didn't ah but the the same drawer
has apparently been able to come up with
those same things
okay fine but I must get different
question yeah so so I'm trying to
understand when somebody says I'm doing
construction of the 17 go yeah I think
two differences following right now this
second argument of geometric scene is a
little bit like sauce you can give
something that's kind of non locally
refers to each also and the first
variable can be ten equations later it
constructions would be if the ends plus
one object contains only variables from
the Phils ten steps so you mean it's
like replace as opposed it's going
forward and I'll use what you have an
expert CT tell you what to do next so
question I mean in in the case of I mean
that's what we do is replace with slash
dot for example which solve you know
where a solve is able to kind of look
ahead to a bunch of those things so I
get that but in the in the primitives
that we have here are they adequate to
describe a construction like we say take
the bisector of this and this do this do
this do this how would it look like if
you were doing construction you have to
say like C equals angle bisector okay
but then the result of all of that would
be if you unravel that it will be some
expression like the one like one of the
ones that we have here won't it right
but this kind of given to construction
make this the hot sink is kind of right
and none no cos one basically in
triangular form so to speak right but I
mean in a sense the construction is
going to be have a unique result yeah in
this case now yes or no like
construction does not have to be unique
like to pick a fill spur and pick a
second point fair enough nothing unique
okay well then that then but when it
meet when you say make a construction
there is an expression like the 17 gone
the result of doing that construction is
an expression isn't it in terms of
whatever initial point you take it's
gonna be some expression involving
bisectors of this and circles around
that and so on relative to the initial
point you take I mean maybe I'm entirely
following but I mean a construction is a
sequence of steps right so this is going
to be it's not the final result right so
it's going to be a list of of things
no I'm talking about its final result
that you have constructed I'm saying
evaluate the C equals blah blah blahs
and then the result of all of that is
going to be this combined thing that you
create yeah I would claim up to some
trivial sort of degeneracies will end up
being you know here's a 17 gone or
something won't it yes okay so ideally
if like we have a graph and all the
steps has been mentioned as like a
geometric assertion then is wrong Fangio
met conjecture they come it should
return like something like geometric
assertion regular polygons with 17
points in eight actually but I thought
very committee understood even steam was
wondering if if we can kind of averse to
seeing and give something and give a
sequence of consecutive steps that leads
to the object well that was a different
thing I was simply asking what does it
even mean if we want to make computable
Gauss's construction that of the 17 gone
what would that mean that this has no
meaning in our adult because the the the
special thing in the Gaussian
construction is that you only can take
square roots and not any cube would ever
but because we use numerical techniques
we have no notion of doing only
operation equivalent mathematically to
taking a square root oh yes I mean if
you're saying solve for given this
object the thing you were just
mentioning given this object solve for
the sequence of steps to get to that
object using rule encompass I understand
we haven't built that at this point does
anybody worry about that anymore I mean
back in the day people you know 50 100
years ago people were quite keen on you
know given this thing constructed with
really ruler and compass does anybody
care about that anymore well we can we
have the functionality to do ruler
compass and computer but it's always a
one-step process people care about
constructive geometry generally but I
don't necessarily depends on your
definition of care right I mean people
still teach that when they're you know
teaching Euclid they teach how to given
this object you make a construction
this way I don't ever remember really
learning that in a class where well I
certainly did in my eighth grade
geometry class but if but certainly did
you ever take like a college you know
Euclidean geometry class because you
know if you're reading you know there
are certainly classes where they you
know to actually teach Euclid and if
you're reading Euclid and you have to be
able to do this to follow his proofs
right okay the most more interesting
seeing in this direction not the things
that you can't do with school or in
compass well yes but that's that's a
ruler compass q which we'll get to one
day which is kind of the question of
whether things can be done with
quadratic he says you know things or not
alright okay let's wrap this meeting up
we need to continue so we should go
ahead and implement this new named font
and you sure that's what we get well not
have project managers I we all just have
to send these back and forth if you
heard but Carla just announced her
presence so if you put it someplace she
has it it's under geometry in the IB
folders okay I said okay alright and
people on the live stream by the way we
are about to start another meeting about
general Wolfram language updates so see
there talk to you all soon okay